Time is a dimension.
Just like length, breadth or height.
But whereas we can move
in any direction
in those other three dimensions
we can only move
in one direction of time -
forward, relentlessly.
Why?
Why can't we ever move
backwards in time?
For a long while
scientists couldn't come up
with a convincing explanation.
The laws of physics, you see,
work fine whether you're going
forwards or backwards in time.
Their answer finally came
from an unexpected place -
steam engines.
At the start
of the industrial revolution
engineers were trying to understand
how to make steam engines
more efficient.
In examining how all that heat
and energy moved around an engine,
they developed a whole new
branch of science
which they called, appropriately,
thermodynamics.
But it turned out that thermodynamics
could explain the behaviour of a lot
more than just steam engines.
In particular, the second law of
thermodynamics helps us to understand
why things happen
in the order that they do.
A cup smashes on the floor
for example,
and spills out all its contents.
Now, we inherently know that
that process is irreversible.
Cups smash.
Things have a way of
disorganising themselves
but they're not so good
at reorganising themselves
and the second law of thermodynamics
tells us why.
Another way of looking at it
is in terms of messiness.
A cup is tidy.
A smashed cup is messy.
The word for this in physics is...
The more entropy there is in a place,
the more disordered,
messy and useless it is.
Here's what the second law
of thermodynamics looks like.
This 'S' represents entropy
and this 'd' is a mathematical way
of representing change.
So 'dS' simply means
a change in entropy.
Now if you look at this equation
from left to right
what it says is that
the entropy of a system
always has to increase.
When a cup smashes
or a freezer defrosts
that's fine according to
the second law of thermodynamics
because the entropy
of those things increases.
But if you expect melted ice
to reassemble
you're expecting entropy to fall.
That would break the second law.
That's a no-no.
The second law tells us what order
things can happen in the universe.
It gives us a clear direction
for the flow of what we call time -
forward.
Time simply can't flow any other way
because that would decrease entropy
and break the second law.
But where is the relentless march
of time taking us?
The entropy of the universe,
the disorder is always increasing.
Always.
At some point in the far future
this means that our entire universe
will be in a state of total disorder,
a state of maximum entropy.
Scientists call it the 'heat death'.
This is how our universe will end.
But don't worry, this bleak fate
won't come upon us any time soon.
The universe
will have to wait trillions
and trillions
and trillions more years,
by which time of course
there will be no humans left to see
how time and entropy
have ravaged our universe.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)